I don't need you anymore hey house Cowan
boss what the [ __ ] is good welcome back
to Resident Evil we're getting there
that's right we're getting there boys
and girls
I don't want to discriminate my female
audience now apparently no you know what
[ __ ] it let's just go okay what do we
got here we need the crank for [ __ ]
sake
so I read the comments and appreciate
the spoilers by the way that's very nice
there we go
apparently there's gonna be a choice
soon between if I should choose Mia or
Zoe I would pick Zoe you know 100% cuz
Mia is she's just a crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I would not stick my dick and name
she lost it all right what kind of weird
disease would you get I don't know is
that weird for me to comment about these
things I think it is a little weird
I'm just being painfully honest okay Zoe
however you know we haven't seen her be
[ __ ] weird and [ __ ] actually she off
[ __ ] sake another one of these where
do I go then there better not be any
[ __ ] crocodiles and [ __ ] there's
another Bridge here okay it's a puzzle
ain't it Annie I can't stop singing in
it now because of that [ __ ] video I
did with Ken here we go we're gonna have
a gun [ __ ] ready you never know
what's gonna pop up in this game got my
one ammo gun hey hell yeah speaking of
load ammo we can change ammo and now we
have a lot more
hell yeah [ __ ] all right doing
pretty well so far what do you think I
can't you know I can't hear you if you
don't [ __ ] speak Jesus Christ [ __ ] at
least they don't [ __ ] explode this
time I need these [ __ ] cranked all
the time
and making me cranky and there we go
everybody
top of the mornin to you oh I hate these
[ __ ] jacksepticeye got him oh god
he's on there you go nice little spicy
you did there
[ __ ] no more of these [ __ ] I swear to
God
okay great all right all right Ellis's
take your time pants you got plenty of
time Oh God
Oh God running low on time don't panic
don't harm planning getting a live in
Jesus Christ everyone come in everyone
calm down
what I blocked what the [ __ ] [ __ ] guys
go gentle on me it's my first time
shucks and really [ __ ] takes care of
those [ __ ] don't thing oh god he's
still alive still alive ah hello Beth -
God um great that went great didn't it
that went so great let's never do that
again ever [ __ ] ever how it's my ammo
got plenty of ammo I got so much ammo
I'll [ __ ] hear another one
[ __ ] I'm running out of ammo like a
[ __ ] I'm just gonna run for it
this is [ __ ] let me turn my meter
let me sir thank you
[ __ ] you ain't worth it alright
plus I have no ammo so I'm [ __ ] no don't
die now are you [ __ ] kidding me
hey how you doing Hayden Hayden that's
great
close that [ __ ] door thank you jesus
[ __ ] christ
jesus [ __ ] christ minecraft is a veil
oh my god not sure if i was supposed to
run there but we did it that was pretty
[ __ ] stressful jesus jgo jex hey look
at that
thank you game for finally giving me
[ __ ] [ __ ] can make anything great
well I have solid fuel I know I have it
the shotgun is the [ __ ] best in this
game I swear to God
do we have everything we need and here
we go how's everyone do it top burner a
new area oh my god it's the girls are
you doing ladies
Zoe are you okay we don't have the time
do you have both ingredients you look
like you're about to [ __ ] yourself girl
I mean Mia how you doing huh okay don't
do any crazy [ __ ] I'm tired of you doing
crazy [ __ ] alright it's [ __ ] annoying
don't make me regret this mia mama mia
pizzeria am i right
god yes wait is that my mind can i no
grab that ah come on man alright what
are you okay and give me the serum and
give me that on do this and do that
Jesus Christ how about a hey thanks for
saving my life out there going through
demons and [ __ ] how about that give me a
damage in yeah just [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright we got that and then we got that
back alright there you go I think we
have the rest do we have to go back all
the way
no that'd be annoying hurry and give me
the ceremony yes I give me the theremin
great and here there should be enough
right it would make him fast enough my
father Lucas not far away
daddy's coming good there you go have
fun with us all right I'm gonna see how
you make this what the [ __ ] are you
doing down there yeah without the serum
the [ __ ] did you just do
you [ __ ] weird little drug girl okay
you know what I'm one of those man when
it is man oh whoa whoa whoa what the
Legend of Zelda call they want their
boss back what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are we in the Kokoro tree what the hell
is this
[ __ ] is this all that one pretty good
didn't it that was pretty great
okay we got one I guess we got to get
all of them [ __ ] sake
got him come on show me your right got
him [ __ ] he follows me so you got to
shoot the pole series nice you won't
sell there was a box up here I swear I
saw a bunch are you dead yet there's the
box
there's the eye isn't it
come on show me your ball
I appreciate the invite but I'm not
interested I'm really nice it's cool to
a hey yeah oh [ __ ] you man
box there we go now where were we I need
to shoot like Oh God I think you just
have one left
I don't know where it is though where
the [ __ ] is is I jeez this is bad I'm
not scared
Hey you look so sexy I've done this
before when I was 14 alright I think I
know how to beat this boss no stop
moving so [ __ ] much no [ __ ] way
I'm out of ammo on that one [ __ ] yes got
him
is there any more ice enough with a
[ __ ] ice
oh there's one isn't it no all right I'm
gonna get out of here cuz I don't like
them
this is bad are there don't mind me
okay great
good for you good for you buddy show me
that pretty eye again
okay that's great show me policeman ed
please be dead I'm really low on ammo
every great if you die now
thank you appreciate it hey we did
everything get it because of the eyes
hilarious
I haven't been to Japan though I've been
seen Japan
hey and so it he said no I meant
evidence are you kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me how are you not dead
no I'm not wasting it
that's real Nick hey oh no now we only
have one serum yes this is gonna be
awkward so you're right now we only have
one [ __ ] also ah damn there was a there
was a boxing yeah all right I almost
missed a bunch of boxes good one good
one that was fun I like that boss fight
hey a boat and everything how y'all
doing hi it's one of them there's only
one left there's only one left there
can't just be one left
what the hell are we gonna do now I mean
you you really just said all right so
now I choose between Zoe and Mia I
assume that you know who's hotter okay
eenie meenie miney moe catch Oh God
Edgar just farted okay I'll go with me
yeah I don't I mean I don't it's fine it
was foolish thinking I could escape but
Zoe go Oh didn't you just go all right
come with us I'm sure there's someone
who can help this is not home
apparently I belong here okay on my ass
don't bother
there won't be anyone left - all right
well you know I'll send you a postcard
then how about that Coach Carr how's
that great hey Mia you want a sweater
you called guess what don't carry got
him I I think most of the comments were
like you should pick me yes I'm like all
right fine
I probably would have picked me I mean
we came for her anyway like that was the
reason we we went I don't we don't know
much about Zoey at all like it wouldn't
really make sense to pick Zoey I think
it's more of a choice that you kind of
go with if you replay the game or some
[ __ ] like that I don't know
oh god you look so creepy thank you
choose
girls you say one wrong thing and it's
just like nope I know you've been
through a lot we need to talk
you learn something to do with all this
didn't you
look I just want to know the truth Ethan
I honestly don't remember try
Oh God oh god what the [ __ ] is that
is that the book [ __ ] did that get here
oh jeez I hate abandoned boats they're
[ __ ] terrifying
oh god no you're okay the hell was that
no no oh [ __ ]
god [ __ ] dammit god dammit Cthulhu
has returned everyone oh geez what is
this we're playing a memory now aren't
we no turn drive lane
we're playing as me thanks for their
reflection there so we know I didn't
just suddenly reverse puberty that's
good
all right back to the basic games like
to do this that built you up and then
the youn they knock you down right
before the finale
[ __ ] every time pretty cool
area
I'd say Sammy thought out I look like
anything you don't look too good
well the demon has even now nothing we
can do about it it would be funny if
like we went through all this [ __ ] to
save this girl right and then as soon as
anything happened to us it's like I well
I guess I supposed I gotta go I mean
I've been here three years a long time
well we're going in the boat just what I
wanted
just what I wanted trust me this is
exactly what I want with my life
going inside abandoned creepy ass boats
that's that's just the best in it
oh god it's even worse on the inside
than I thought oh my god yeah oh my god
yeah disgusting I wonder if the boat has
anything to do with life what happened
to the family that would make sense
maybe the dad found like some some weird
Russian experiments
what wait sorry my ass is itching okay
was that it was a memory Mia it was a
memory oh I like how there's a
flashlight in my eyes love when that
happens okay I guess we go up up up up
up to the top I'm just trying to [ __ ]
see oh my god not moist monsters [ __ ]
this is the moist game I have ever
played what do you think
name one moist air game than this one
moisture it's not a word I think it is
after you played this game hello
what if again give me something a gun
anything [ __ ]
whoa what the [ __ ] are you talking about
we need some weapons so any weapons on
this ship oh okay I was like where
should I go and then game was like
you're welcome
wow what a great way to go creepy
corridors people like to get in your
face and be like hey what up
it's your boy Ethan but I bet it
anything here nope anything here yes
anything down down we go
yak yak yak yak oh god it's saving
autosave always means bad news in video
games at least horror game could there
be guns here oh my god dude you [ __ ]
little weirdo must have been hiding for
something great something Pleasant I'm
sure this one you know that's not how
you take a [ __ ] but you were pretty
close pretty close buddy don't do that
again okay we're fine hey shower would
be nice
shouldn't you be looking for Ethan
she's inside me well I guess that's what
happens when you [ __ ] people this way
please
oh wow
okay I wasn't expecting this [ __ ] your
now okay can we go anywhere from here
okay we can
hey look it's Annabelle typical boat
that looked like us doesn't it it does
look like guys okay well that makes me
look feel a little safer I don't know
why what's wrong with girls
little tiny girls are so creepy and
weird like we should all just send them
off you know somewhere they can't hurt
anyone I don't like it I don't like them
all right I'm gonna be honest I don't
like them creepy and me
oh geez this place looks cool there can
you guys shut the [ __ ] up ah god it's
all not my new shoes damn it how do I
get out oh there we go [ __ ] make me
walk through this goddamn maze hey there
you are
yeah no I'm while I [ __ ] lied all
right those are not even gucci boots
wait I'll go this way
I'll go this one apparently they're so
long
ah jeez hey it's a box everybody can't
break it though could there be guns in
here perhaps hey it's a herb everyone
it's been preserved it was so well
everything else is rot in bed you know
it's some good good oh god what is
happening over there
I dunno oh [ __ ] I need to find a gun
fast [ __ ] I don't have a [ __ ] gun
[ __ ] off honestly hey look it's me now
wait it's just trash damn it
Oh what the [ __ ] oh my god what the hell
man I don't have a [ __ ] guy like
honestly [ __ ] off can I hide it Li's
what the hell
I mean they wouldn't put a box here
unless they gave me a knife or some [ __ ]
for [ __ ] sake that thing just patrols
I guess we need a [ __ ] this is really
bad
what about in here
maybe there's a gun here no just demons
just demons everyone no big deal I don't
like this you know oh my god oh thank
god is safe
Jesus Christ I thank God for doors man
thank [ __ ] god for doors oh hey buddy
there it is that's what I won't what do
we want a gun with to Amazon [ __ ] to
ammo
[ __ ] to ammo shots that's all be gay
you only get one shot do not miss the
chance there you go
oh hello Beth there they borrow fun okay
well I blew it I blew it
I blew it I admit I blew it that's fine
that's fine it's fine as long as you run
nothing bad will ever happen oh my god
all right that's fine let's just go in
here see what happens all right the door
is closed you're now held master you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no no Jeff Blair okay well that's fine
okay that's fine you know it's fine
I feel great you're not welcome in here
[ __ ] that's right moist monsters
hey there's the fuse all right I'll take
it
thank you sir would you mind if I lick
your titties okay I won't do that then
all right hey hey how are you doing okay
you're in the air - that's great dude
it's like a whole family party in here I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't know
me you know I'm gonna go in here now and
cry a little bit yeah but you're not
invited what I say what I say what I say
yeah you stay in there and you think
about what you've done all right let me
just put this [ __ ] thing in and I'm
the [ __ ] out of here all right I'm gonna
get the [ __ ] out oh oh we did it that
was stressful my god okay well we have
pretty much nothing going for us right
now I think we can make a health pack
that's good
sounds like a demoness in there so I'm
not gonna go there right now should we
open justice it's locked anyway well I
feel so defenseless [ __ ] sex is a man
just cuz I'm playin is a girl dissing me
top bottom on ante up
all right oh jeez oh there's a TV in
here how is the electricity running in
this [ __ ] place you know what I
shouldn't jump double you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what why you need to remember be
a family listen I'm not gonna watch
grown ups 2 with you it's a [ __ ] movie I
don't care how much you love it fine all
right fine
get it over with it's truly it's a
horror game making me watch Adam Sandler
movies god damn it
this is one of another one of those
where I have to play the I have to play
the cutscene or whatever I don't like
that it scares me alright I want to be I
want to feel safe but it's a horror game
poets I know I know
goddamnit worse
hey yeah that's the same Apple watch but
it serves me right it's my fault she got
out yeah it is your fault that doesn't
mean I'm gonna let you die
she didn't attack you it's part of her
imprinting protocol you believe this is
happening yeah take it it has her tissue
samples so that's the bottle we were
carrying in turn fix this okay Evie
where are you hey ya box whoa p90
nineteen a knife dude I'm a [ __ ] I'm
a boss I drink sauce do you drink sauce
uh uh-huh alright you hang tight buddy
you hang tight I'm shoot some [ __ ]
the little girls for that [ __ ] it we
have a lot ammo I don't like that
it's cozy now though I like it target
acquired the numbers displays okay
[ __ ] it's locked from there hey we got
some supplements oh here we go okay
she's vomiting she's vomiting well he
needs to stop doing that
after we said we're not right now Ellen
how's it going she's vomiting far more
in excess of her body mass all right
find her and fast so the moist is her
vomit what the [ __ ] did you drink last
night
oh I get it so this is just her vomit
it's not actually her my bad
there they are not so close please thank
you man that's some ugly-ass vomit man
oh my god I gotta sneeze no [ __ ] hey
look it's her
can you stop vomiting god damn it
did she leave anything here we can take
the stairs
hey drugs
my favorite there's just Aris want to
keep looting a little bit this video is
sponsored by Apple watch or some [ __ ]
like wait where's the stairs it's not it
okay now let me oh god what is that oh
jeez dude that's cool I was going down
anyway I love that [ __ ]
everything is awesome everything is cool
when you're part of that put I'm not a
big fan of this place I'm not gonna lie
there's vomit everywhere ASU
thank you appreciate it
there's bound to be more where that come
from
I don't know this yeah I got damn it oh
this is a big one
lock that [ __ ] got them I feel strong
my love oh god oh god what's happening
you can't kill me that's right
[ __ ] hey remote bomb what the
[ __ ] is that a bomb that can be
detonated by remote control press square
to detonate it what that's awesome let's
use it that's one I want to you know use
it on two of them how are you gonna get
down here boy how's your plan - ah [ __ ]
they're stairs
got'em moist monsters bitter Pipitea how
you doing buddy London get on it
okay [ __ ] feel like I'm what is so
linear this part is [ __ ] annoying
[Music]
alright great shoots nearby Alan Alan
I'm busy she's on the other side of the
story but I don't have a key check our
luggage melt you got a blowtorch and a
Furby let's go crazy mean what do we get
jump-scare in three two one never mind
oh how about that what is this
corrosives thanks game
those are my a s if you know what I'm
sorry okay nice I guess we can open the
other doors now we feel like going back
because we have three of them but oh
she's our daughter and not mad okay I'll
be your mommy just just come back with
me right now okay yeah and stop vomiting
it's [ __ ] annoying where is she
oh there she is don't don't [ __ ] up
oh geez did you find her
yes but yes she's making more friends
Alan those things are everywhere
are you okay
about
good fault
ah perfect ah come on
ah come on man all right why not
all right it's time to go boom
for [ __ ] sake you just crippled them
ah just let me pass thank you ain't
nobody got time for you guys what a
waste what a waste have a beautiful bomb
all right which way all right let's go
in here
I don't know trying to stay [ __ ] calm
right now
hold it [ __ ] goin down we got herb so we
got guns more bombs hell yeah and more
corrosive perfect excellent more [ __ ]
I'll take it take all this [ __ ] I can
get yes I gotta show you
thank you good to see you buddy I'm
gonna skip you
not this [ __ ] again
ah listen
Oh what the [ __ ] I couldn't block okay
Jesus this bad
godom [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
no [ __ ] hurt
all right hey I stopped off by Borla
emergency safety walk down system has
been engaged excellent just what I
needed
god damn I'm playing a memory right
I forgot I did that I was way
doesn't tell me mr. Allen was right
now with [ __ ] sake where do you go
Allen one where the hell are you thanks
Allen why were the only ones left on
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
we already looted everything here there
should be a door yeah I remember I here
we go
beautiful I want these
hey bombs I'll take them
oh geez
that's awesome huh
[ __ ] yeah all right here's another one
Hayden I am lucky Oh [ __ ] sake okay I
thought it was a door
yeah I guess maybe we can go here now
nope okay not cool man Hey look at that
no another one spawned for [ __ ] sake
god damn it I thought I was gonna blow
up the door what a [ __ ] waste [ __ ] I
don't know where to go oh my god there's
a [ __ ] thing here I took me forever
come on
hey back at it again alright where's the
stairs
where's the goddamn stairs there they
are
I should have should have been obvious
hey everyone let's just go straight at
it though me why don't we why shall we
getting tired of this game me yeah
target acquired [ __ ] I'm gonna
spray you that's probably a bad idea
we have anything in here I don't want to
keep you looking for stuff right now
just go for it
hey it's Alan by ocean yeah how do you
get here without the treatment she's
deteriorating don't say that
she god damn your face is ugly that
little [ __ ] she never trusted me jeez
Oh careful who you call a [ __ ] in high
school oh my god it reminds me of fear
so much that old video game alright we
did it yeah no we didn't we're dead
we're dead we're [ __ ] then yeah ah for
[ __ ] sake
god damn it oh it's everywhere now
[Music]
Oh still got my gun oh yeah MA oh my god
all right man or whatever your name is
Evelyn getting real tired of this [ __ ]
we're watching a movie inside a movie
yeah why not you're gonna press play or
what
what are you doing
it's me we're recording it now I did
like I shouldn't have if you get this
yes stay away forget that you ever knew
me say
[Music]
and let's just tweet that out so who the
[ __ ] is Ethan in this equation like just
a boyfriend just random boyfriend if you
pick the wrong girlfriend oh geez
oh my god alright I get it you know
this is so like beer like straight up oh
my god
Wow
oh my god Jesus Christ
Oh No that's bad that's real that's a
bad everyone that's a bad look we left
our body we all be together forever
goddamn I hate little girls start the
worst the worst yes Oh disgusting I
think it's time we end that episode
there it's gonna be the last episode
next one so I'll see you tomorrow with a
final episode what's gonna happen I
don't know but it's pretty good I hope
you enjoy this episode it'll be like if
you did and as always thank you so much
for watching stay awesome Bres jeez
sorry I remember I guess I was a little
more no Evie you can't be a family we
were never a family we will never be a
family jesus what a [ __ ] [ __ ]